hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about omega-3 versus omega-6 balance in
our diet if you are a diet conscious
individual you might have come across
these terms omega-3 and omega-6
chemically speaking these are
polyunsaturated fatty acid meaning they
have multiple double Bonds in them
people have a misconception they think
omega-3 fatty acids are the best and
omega-6 are bad but this is completely
wrong in fact omega-6 fatty acid is much
better than saturated fatty acids that
we can find butter palm oil or in animal
products
omega-6 fatty acid if consumed in
moderation can be good for heart health
it should not cause any problem but the
problem occurs when you have a altered
balance between omega-3 and omega-6s
major source of omega-6 is vegetable
oils otherwise it can also be found from
animal sources seeds and nuts
balance between omega-6 and omega-3 is
absolutely essential in our diet
indeed our ancestor has a proper balance
between omega-6 and Omega-3s but these
days we consume more omega-6 and less
Omega-3
current Western diet contains 20 times
higher omega-6 compared to omega-3 and
that's pretty daunting so next time when
you think about eating a burger think
twice earlier we used to focus on
natural products like we our ancestors
used to hunt and gather fresh food so
their balance was maintained but when we
are consuming packaged product like this
burger we are consuming more omega-6
compared to Omega-3
so next time when you eat the burger I
would let you know that there are tons
and tons of omega-6 in these fried and
deep fried products
so
let me tell you that Mediterranean diet
is specially enriched in omega-3 because
they have a lot of oily fish olive oils
in that particular diet
compared to a western diet omega-3
containing Mediterranean diet is much
healthy
omega-3 is good for heart health
inflammation
in context of cancer joint health
depression and it's also good for
pregnant women
a recent study found out that the
incidence of death per 100 000
individual for a heart disease is way
more in U.S population compared to Spain
so Spain follows a Mediterranean diet
whereas U.S population is generally
consuming processed food enriched in
omega-6
so what we learned
balance is
now when there is a visit balance
between
India and omega-6 and omega-6 is
increased it also increased the risk of
heart disease inflammation high blood
pressure and it might lead to
vasoconstriction as well
so what is the solution simple solution
is to reduce the consumption of omega-6
and increase the consumption of Omega-3
in our diet
omega-6 fatty acids such as arachidonic
acid is the base material to create
prostaglandins prostaglandins are key
mediators of inflammation
now let me tell you that prostaglandin
is synthesized by a complicated process
but the key enzyme in this process is
positively regulated by omega-6 fatty
acid and negatively regulate omega-3
fatty acid that's why we tell omega-3
fatty acid is anti-inflammatory whereas
omega-6 is pro-inflammatory
now energy donic acid can be converted
into other substances like
prostacyclines also thromboxins
thromboxins are are compound that can
lead to vasoconstriction that means
constriction of the blood vessels this
might increase blood pressure and that
could be detrimental for us it would
increase the chances of heart attack
arachidonic acid which is omega-6 fatty
acid can also give rise to leukotrienes
leukotriines can have adverse effect on
our
alveoli and also in our bronchioles so
it lead to bronchoconstriction that
means it increases the chance of
developing asthma that means several
omega-6 products are pretty harmful for
us it leads to many
problems in our health
generally omega-6 is not harmful
if the substances that are generated
from omega-6 fatty acid are overproduced
in the body that would lead to the
danger
that simply means our moral of the story
is balanced intake of omega-3 and
omega-6 is really important for a
healthy life if you like this video give
it a quick thumbs up don't forget to
like share and subscribe